[Music]
one thing that i think our company's
pretty well known for is having the
value of move fast i've always believed
that values are only useful
if you can
like legitimately disagree with them
right so i've always thought like values
like be honest are like not that helpful
because like of course you have to be
honest right it's like i feel bad even
needing to write that down if you have
to write that down then something
something kind of went wrong but i don't
know any good company that doesn't that
doesn't focus on kind of honesty or
demand that of of their of their
employees so from my perspective that's
not like a useful
you know if you only get to write down
like five or six concepts to to kind of
program into your culture
you want them to be things that good
companies can reasonably do differently
and i think part of this is that good
values you need to be able to give
something up in order to get them so
around move fast you know we've always
had this this question it's like you
can't just tell people to move fast the
question is like what's the deal like
what are you what are you willing to
give up and famously it used to be move
fast and break things and the the idea
was that we tolerated some amount of
bugs in the software in order to
basically encourage people to move
quickly because it's like moving fast i
think is the key to learning right it's
like you want to increase the iteration
cycle so you can get feedback from from
the people you serve quickly and and
then incorporate that into the product
so we would literally get into
situations where you know it's
competitors of us would ship you know
once a year once every six months and
we'd ship code every day and it's like
of course we're going to learn faster
and we're going to build something
better if you're shipping something
every day so the question is what are
you willing to give up so it used to be
we would tolerate some amount of defects
in the product now it got to the point
is that as the company grew
that we were producing so many bugs that
going back and fixing them was actually
slowing us down more than than we were
speeding up so i still thought okay like
moving fast this is still like a really
important thing we've got to change how
we do it so
we we kind of evolved to
building a somewhat less sexy phrase
move fast with stable infrastructure and
then basically the new the new bet was
we're going to invest disproportionately
in building up good infrastructure and
abstractions inside our company so that
way the average engineer who comes here
is going to be much faster and more
productive at getting things done than
in other places and
you know at a scale of almost 100 000
people i think what this really means
now
is like methodically
i don't know it's like companies just
add process over time right it's like
and it's all good intention you know
for the most part right it's like people
are trying to you know make sure that we
don't repeat mistakes that we've made so
you just have this like checklist of
things that everyone needs to do before
they can ship anything
but
most companies don't have a counter
process to that to basically garbage
collect and remove
processes that are no longer that useful
so part of what what i'm really focused
on now
is is just methodically going through
and making sure all of the different
processes that we've built up as a
company still serve us well
in kind of empowering a an effort to go
do that so you know so now that's that's
kind of what move fast is focused on
you